bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors en quoi ce sommet
est particulier aujourd'hui ce qui est
particulier c'est surtout le changement
d'ambiance c'est à dire que la politique
de tron s'était plutôt quand même un
certain l'isolationnisme américain
donc l'idée que l'amérique de 6 des
soldes des grandes décisions en fonction
de ses propres intérêts dubai donne
change la donne dans la mesure où il dit
qu'il fait du multilatéralisme sans
qu'on sache très bien quelle est la
définition de ce terme
mais cela signifie dialogue avec ses
partenaires du g7
avant de prendre des décisions mais il
ne faut pas se faire quand même promis
l'union les états unis s'intéressent
d'abord à leurs intérêts leur objectif
est qu'en fait c'est les partenaires
s'aligne sur les positions des états
unis dans les principaux dossiers qu'il
s'agisse de la question du pot vide
qu'il s'agisse de la question de
l'otan'' est donc derrière les belles
images
nous sommes quand même dans des logiques
géopolitique de rapport de force entre
les pays
finalement c'est un peu l'occasion pour
dubaï donnent leur place et les états
unis au centre du jeu vient de montrer
qu'en fait les états unis ont des alliés
c'est d'ailleurs assez extraordinaire
que cette réunion ait lieu en angleterre
et du coup elles soient présidées par
celui qui vient sortir de l'union
européenne après après le break sic donc
vous voyez que les réalités
géopolitiques sont extrêmement
différentes de cette image d'unité qui
est donnée puisque c'est une désunion le
break site qui est intervenu au sein des
lignes européennes
alors il ya des éléments positifs et des
éléments négatifs
l'une des grandes problématiques
négative c'est que 30 dans sa conception
unilatérale des états unis obliger les
pays de l'union européenne à
s'intéresser davantage à leur propre
sécurité à leur propre défense et la
dubai donne revient à la position
d'avant où il dit aux européens bah
finalement vous allez continuer d'avoir
le parapluie
de protection des états unis et donc
nous entendu c'est pas la peine de faire
des efforts pour votre défense
donc ceci n'est pas forcément
souhaitable pour ceux qui considèrent
que les pays de l'union européenne
devraient être capables d'assurer eux
mêmes leur propre défense et on y vient
on parle de boris johnson c'est son
premier sommet du g7 post break fit il
est aisé d'imaginer que c'est une
réunion avec beaucoup d'enjeu pour lui
lewis a beaucoup d'enjeu pour lui
d'abord il s'agit pour lui aussi de
compenser les inconvénients du break 6
avec un rapprochement avec les états
unis
il s'agit quand même de montrer à
l'union européenne que le break 6 à
venir le royaume il a retrouvé sa
souveraineté et qu'il fait ce qu'il
entend et qu'il n'est pas obligé de
suivre les directives de l'union
européenne dans l'autre élément de ce
sommet pour souligner ce qu'il met en
évidence que j'appellerais le retard en
mouillage des membres du g7 par rapport
aux comics 19
c'est à dire qu'il y à déjà des mois que
la chine a mis en oeuvre une diplomatie
des masques notamment en afrique et dans
de nombreux pays du sud pour se
valoriser les deux pays les vaccins vous
avez à la fois la russie et la chine
sont lancés dans une grande diplomatie
du dax 1 en distribuant massivement des
vaccins dans des pays du sud
donc c'est ce sommet qui est en train de
le décider pour le g7
mais en fait le g7 est très sympa sur
les actions géopolitiques liés au vaccin
conduite à la chine et à l'inde mais
l'accélération de la vaccination celle
ci est l'objectif de cette réunion de se
sauver justement est-ce que c'est pas un
peu contradictoire de dire d'un côté ne
lèvera pas les brevets c'est impossible
et de l'autre dire oui nous allons vous
donner
et plein de vaccins nous voulons que des
pays les plus pauvres soient vaccinés de
la même façon que l'on vaut il ya en
fait c'est déjà trop tard c'est à dire
qu'en réalité vous rappeler que les
états unis déjà sous tron mais même sur
dubaï bonn ont toujours dit nous
vaccinons d'abord notre propre
population
le seul pays qui a mixé psion pour les
etats unis c'est le maxi parce que les
états unis ont négocié avec le maxi en
iso au mexique en vous donne des vaccins
en priorité par rapport aux autres pays
mais vous contrôlez mieux votre
frontière parce qu'on veut pas qu'il est
trop des migrants qui arrivent aux états
unis mais la décision aujourd'hui on est
plutôt dans des dents des éléments d fed
annonce puisque pour le moment
malheureusement les taux de vaccination
dans les pays du sud sont très faibles
ils sont très faibles notamment parce
que les pays des gestes du g7 ont donné
priorité à leur propre population
alors que des pays comme la russie et la
chine dès le début on a la foi vacciner
leurs propres populations et distribué
terrain très largement des vaccins à des
pays du sud pour en tirer des avantages
géopolitiques ont réussi et et finance
d'ailleurs les grandes absentes de ce
sommet question plus générale
quelle est aujourd'hui la valeur du g7
sont la chine sont la russie finlande
également alors que il ya le g20 est
maintenant bien vous rappeler que
d'abord le g7 était algérie pendant un
certain nombre d'années c'est à dire que
ce sont les membres du g7 qui ont exclu
la chine et du cookie du collège de la
russie par dans nos esprits la russie
bien entendu dix ans que j'essaie
aujourd'hui est un élément de
préparation comme vous l'avez très bien
dit on au g20 mais son poilu nos
politiques a considérablement diminué
parce que d'une part dans la russie a
pris un poids significatif filiale a
montré qu'elle avait été capable de
réorganiser ses éléments de défense et
surtout grande surprise personne ne
s'attendait à ce que la russie si
rapidement puisse elle-même fabriquer
des vaccins contre contre le comique 19
et donc elle a prouvé qu'elle avait
aussi des outils technologiques
l'ap dans l'industrie pharmaceutique et
même si la russie n'avait pas les moyens
de production de ces vaccins
vous savez qu'elle a recouru à l'âne qui
elle a une industrie manufacturière très
importante pour produire le vaccin russe
et le distribuer dans de nombreux pays
du monde l'attend à lachine vous pouvez
donc aujourd'hui c'est à côté des
etats-unis la grande puissance
géopolitique avec tout son projet sur
les routes de la soie et peu de tout ce
qu'elle peut faire pour effectivement
assumées ses représentants demande est
essentielle nous ne voyons très bien
avec nos caves d'afrique est ce qu'on
aurait pu imaginer que la chine ne
s'intéresse qu'aux pays africains qui
ont les meilleures ressources ou que
pays africain dans le nombre de
consommateurs est très élevé et qui
représente un potentiel significatif
lorsque vous regardez la présence
chinoise en chine c'est dans tous les
pays d'appeler voyez une stratégie de
présence géopolitique partout et donc
cela signifie avec une ambition qui est
planétaire
merci gérard françois dumont d'avoir
répondu à nos questions se rappelle que
vous êtes géographes économistes
démographes mercer